From January 6th Facts to
Way alongside
Tucker Carlson's new January 6th Fantasy.
The Justice Department
says 1000 people are facing
federal or local charges.
Nearly one
third of them
are charged
with assaulting, resisting
or impeding officers
or Capitol employees that day.
140 police officers were assaulted
when the pro-Trump mob
stormed the Capitol that day.
Your eyes did not lie
when you saw the windows smashed
and the barriers breached.
Your ears did not deceive you.
Hang Mike Pence
and find
Nancy were among the outrages
we all heard chanted during the assault.
But Tucker
Carlson now is lying
and deceiving his own loyal viewers.
Speaker McCarthy,
you remember, gave the Fox host
exclusive access
to thousands of hours of footage
We're going to get inside with footage
that shows you
what was actually happening
inside the Capitol.
The footage does not show an insurrection
or a riot in progress.
Instead, it shows police
escorting protesters through the building
that remember the man
you just saw there
helped Donald Trump lie
that the 2020 election was stolen.
He now wants you to believe
the anger in the violence
we all saw that day was the exception.
The crowd was enormous.
A small percentage of them
were hooligans.
They committed vandalism.
You've seen their pictures
again and again.
But the overwhelming majority weren't.
They were peaceful.
They were orderly and meek.
These were not insurrectionists.
They were sightseers
in.
And Sara Murray joins our conversation.
Sara, you have spent hours and hours
and hours covering
the January 6th committee
hearings, covering a lot of these cases,
making their way through the courts.
You know that
what he's just said there is fantasy
before you jump in.
And I just want to say, he
they have trained people to say
don't believe people like us.
How about Republican senators?
There were a lot of people
in the Capitol at the time who I think
were scared for their lives
so that you can,
you know, everyone describe it.
But it was a
it was an attack on the Capitol.
I think that breaking through glass
windows and doors
to get into the United States
Capitol against the orders of
police is a crime.
Point is, what happened
that day shouldn't have happened.
Three quite conservative
members of the United States
Senate essentially saying, no, not true.
Why? Well, because it's not true.
Because Tucker Carlson
is trying to whitewash, you know,
what happened on January six.
He sort of went through
he cherry picked
the moments in this video
where, you know,
they were not showing the violence
that was unfolding.
It was not showing rioters
who were attacking police.
It was not showing the moment, said
Brian sickNick, who we know
lost his life
the next day,
was being tear gassed
and then trying to recover
from being attacked by rioters.
He chose not to play those moments
he chose to play some of these moments
of relative calm.
I think that's why
we're seeing this pushback
from Republican senators.
That's why we saw outrage today
from the head of U.S. Capitol Police.
That's why we are seeing,
you know,
very reasonable outrage
from the sickNick family after what
Tucker said
Tucker Carlson tried to do last night.
And if you watch Tucker Carlson again,
he tried to help Donald Trump
convince the country
the election was stolen when it was not.
He dabbles in conspiracy quite a bit.
Last night
he was talking about the Cuban on shaman
who was charged
will get to the charges in just a minute.
Tucker Carlson says he was just a
featured guest
the Capitol Police never
stopped Jacob Chansley.
They helped him.
They acted as his tour guides.
We counted
at least nine officers
who were within touching distance
of unarmed Jacob Chansley.
Not one of them
even tried to slow him down.
Chansley
understood that
Capitol Police were his allies
That is Tucker Carlson.
State Capitol Police have testified.
Many of them said
they were just grossly outnumbered
and they were not going to pick
and choose
who they were going to have
confrontations with.
But there's also other video
of the shaman, Mr.
Chansley, going through the Capitol.
You see him there
as part of the initial breach.
Then you see him
later in the Senate chamber
where he's up on the diocese
if he's a member
of the United States Senate,
he is serving a 41 month sentence.
He was one of the first rioters
in the building.
He asked Trump for a pardon.
Tourists don't ask for pardons.
I don't think he was on the left.
A note on the Senate diet
saying it's only a matter of time.
Justice is coming.
And he yelled as he went through
the Capitol.
Mike Pence is an F-ing traitor.
Just a tourist.
Clearly not.
And I mean, what's
striking to me, actually,
is that Tucker
Carlson and his team had access,
exclusive access
to these thousands
and thousands of hours of tape
and didn't actually find
or at least they didn't show anything.
That really does
change our understanding
of what happened that day.
You see
video of the Q and on Shaman and others
sort of milling through the hallways.
But we don't know what the key
moments were before and after that.
And until they released the video
to the rest of the media, we won't know.
Sources
that we've talked to you at the Times
say that
there isn't really a lot
that that counters that narrative at all.
And as Tucker
said on his own show,
most of it is really not that revealing.
What is quite revealing,
though, is aside from the senators,
is the video
you played on the Republican side,
the House Republicans
are very much rallying around this.
The House
Republican Conference
tweeted this video of of Tucker Carlson.
That segment today saying must watch.
This is a rewriting history
that is being embraced
by the Republican Party,
even if there are some senators
within the party
who are willing to say
100 and 130
something of those House Republicans,
even after the attack on the Capitol,
tried to block the certification
of the Electoral College.
So they want to rewrite, whitewash,
wipe away, minimize
the history of that day.
You mentioned Officer sickNick.
I feel nervous doing this.
I don't like to do this.
I don't like to put families back
through the pain
they have suffered every time
they see this video.
But here is Tucker
Carlson's take on Officer sickNick
by all appearances, sickNick is healthy
and vigorous.
He's wearing a helmet,
so it's hard to imagine
he was killed by a head injury.
Whatever happened to Brian
sickNick was very obviously
not the result of violence
he suffered at the entrance
to the Capitol.
Now we can show you some video of Officer
sickNick outside the Capitol
where he was pepper sprayed or bear
sprayed, as they call it,
what he was trying there to hold the line
before the line collapsed.
A Yes, he went inside
and he may have cleaned up
and he may have gotten the sting
out of his eyes,
but he died the next day.
The medical examiner says
it was of natural causes
that he suffered a couple of strokes,
but he died the very next day.
And his family says
the sickNick family is outraged.
The ongoing attack on our family
by the unscrupulous
and outright
sleazy so-called news
network of Fox News,
who will do the bidding of Trump
or any of his sycophant followers
every time the pain that day
seems to have ebbed a bit.
Organizations like Fox
rip our wounds wide open again,
and we are frankly sick of it.
Yeah, I mean, it's
horrible for that family.
It's horrible
for the officers
who had to live through that to see this
and this attempt to erase
what they had to go through the pain,
the fear,
the trauma
of having to hold off that mob,
they were vastly outnumbered.
That's why you see them
sort of seeming to kind of have hands off
with some of the folks who were there.
But listen,
this is exactly what
Kevin McCarthy wanted.
He wants this kind of rewritten.
He wants it downplayed.
And you see Donald Trump
coming out saying
because of Tucker Carlson's lies
about this, that everyone should be freed
who has been detained due to January six
and again,
to the sickNick family and others.
I don't lightly remember that video.
We just think it is necessary
to put the whitewash that you're seeing
into factual context.